زياره رئيسه الوزراء الايطاليه الى طرابلس
التي رافقها فيها وزير الداخليه والخارجيه
ومدير عام شركه لم تكن زياره عاديه
[موسيقى]
الى طرابلس لتوقيع اتفاقيات مع حكومه
الوحده الوطنيه لمجال الامن والمكافحه
الهجره ولكن الاتفاق الابرز كان بين مؤسسه
النفط وشركه والذي اثار
الحقول الملك اليوم للغاز حتى يتناقص
ممكن بعد ثلاثه اربع سنوات بتقدي في
التناق لا بد ان نحافظ
ونزيد كميه الغاز المنتجه بشغطي حتى
احتياجات الشارع اللي بيقول
ان احنا بنصدر الضغط
100% المؤسسه الوطنيه
داخل البحر الابيض المتوسط
وباحتياطه سته لتر مكعب من الغاز
وبعدين التركيبين البحريين
تم استكشافهم في السبعينات
وتم الاعلان التجاري عنهن في 2013 وهذا
الموضوع
سيعود بالنفع على
الاقتصاد الليبي سواء كان في شكل عوائد
تصل الى 18 مليار دولار او كان ايضا
توفير الغاز اللي محطه الكهرباء ولتصدير
ايضا الاتفاقيه التي عززت المكانه الرفيعه
للشركه الايطاليه في السوق الليبي اعادت
من جديد الانقسام السياسي بين الاجسام
المسيطره على المشهد على الانقسام لابد ان
رئيسه الوزراء الايطاليه تعرف ابعاده جيدا
لكنها تحولات الكبيره في سوق الطاقه في
العالم تتجاوز بعض العقبات احيانا على
الرغم من طبيعه الاتفاقيه النفطيه الموقعه
بين طرابلس وروما ولكنها تحمل في طياتها
العديد من الرسائل السياسيه خصوصا في ظل
المنافسه الاوروبيه على النفط والغاز في
ليبيا منير الاشهب طرابلس العربيه